eric zemmour assigne le magazine closer
qui révèlerait la maternité de sa
conseillère ça vient de tomber le point
vient de révéler et eric zemmour et sa
concert si on peut mettre l'article
voilà derrière eric zemmour a sign de
closer qui révèle la mac pérennité de sa
conseillère le polémiste devant
l'interdiction à la vente du magazine
people qui révèle que sa conseillère ça
sert sarah knafo et enceinte celle ci
s'est joint à la procédure ça sortira
demain on aura un gros dossier
d'ailleurs là-dessus demain mais juste
myriam
est ce qu'on peut faire interdire à un
magazine comme ça franchement c'est
extrêmement rare bon je vous cache pas
que moi je suis un peu dégoûté
le public est très bien cette semaine
non mais c'est parce que voilà c'est une
information vous l'aviez vous l'avez
forcément ça ça tourne dans les
rédactions depuis trois semaines sauf
que on a une espèce de voile à de
déontologie je sais ça va faire réagir
ou en fait on ne révèle pas nous les
grossesses avant douze semaines d'accord
moi mes informations le disait qu'elle
n'était pas enceinte encore des douze
semaines donc ni nous ni d'autres
publications people avait pris le parti
de diffuser encore cette information qui
visiblement qu'est causeur et y est allé
et tailles voilà c'est l'art choir dans
mes réserves mais qu'elle est enceinte
en tout cas c'est je ne confirme rien
dire mais en tout cas c'est l'info
effectivement contrôleur n'a depuis deux
trois ans on attendait tous le bond des
dépenses la peau pour la saisir c'est
parce qu'en fait on peut pas révéler une
grosse est comme ça sans fin même qu'on
nomme eric zemmour ou pas c'est dur
s'annonce assez dure c'est compliqué
surtout que c'est un homme marié donc à
la base donc voilà c'est ça sa as
comment dire moi je sais conseils
juridiques mon avis tu le fais pas du
tout juridiquement on va me faire closer
ça c'est quoi ça c'est ça c'est que
c'est quoi comme risqués rôle c'est une
atteinte irréversible a dit vga
l'intimité c'est un futur faut peut-être
possible candidat à la présidence il est
marié effectivement donc c'est plusieurs
mesures choses qui sont aujourd'hui
révélées et donc la grossesse dont il
serait éventuellement le papa et risque
quoique l'odeur closer alors moi je
pense qu'il risque de voir demain se
voir pour la première fois ça peut être
une première mais se voir interdire
effectivement
l'apparition si ce n'est pas le point
aujourd'hui et sur le il peut les juges
peuvent se dire aussi mais finalement il
ya eu 7 cette assignation qui a été fait
on en a parlé et puisqu'on en a parlé
c'est déjà aujourd'hui dans le domaine
public quasiment donc ces îles ont été
squizzée quasiment close art donc mais
il est vrai il pourrait en tout cas si
ce n'est pas une interdiction c'est ce
sont ce seront de forts dommages et
intérêts hier que pénales pour pour les
10 heures et à dire c'est que quel genre
d'homme à une condamnation va après il
va pas lent prison un éditeur dont ce
sera marqué dans son casier ccsa pas lui
jusque là combien ça fait franchement sa
peine 5000 euros ils sont moins trente
mille euros c'est tout on en voit à
terre parce que c'est non non non c'est
non mais pour le non mais pour le
journal trente mille euros s'ils n'ont
rien vu les diffusions est vraiment vous
devez la wii mais là ils se disent ils
vont les faire parce que ça à faire un
tel buzz non mais ça va pas ils vont pas
vendre 30 millions d'emplaires 7 à oui
je suis sûr franchement ça c'est en tant
que directrice et genre de questions
aussi costumes ont peur de leurs jours
que juré ça fait buzz et voilà ça fait
parler du magazine c'est bien encore
mais après de vous dire qu'il veut et
surtout à l aller à les allaiter pas
même inconnu même si on sait
qu'aujourd'hui elle a un rôle important
dans dans la vie professionnelle de
monsieur zemmour en tout cas elle est
totalement inconnue elle n'a jamais
communiqué sur quoi que ce soit des
éléments de sa vie privée en fait les
comptes à partir de là elle risque le
magazine risque également une très forte
condamnant salle est quand même là à
tout tout tout s'est confié à monsieur
encadrent occident
saviez que closer aller le sortirons pas
oui vous savez pas laisser cet après
midi mais vous l'avez pas su inventer un
exode des coiffeurs oui mais je peux pas
en parler mais bon j'ai dit vous êtes
dit ils ont sorti j'aurais dû le faire
ou non j'ai bien fait je vais être
honnête avec vous j'ai ouais j'ai je me
suis dit j'aurais dû le faire bon ben
des plats pas ma pdg mais pas question
donc
c'est bien d'être honnête envers moi
mais bon après voilà je sais que tout le
monde va me tomber dessus mais c'est
vrai que nous on est à nous mais c'est
un truc c'est un peu viscérale ont animé
par six noms mais perso je préfère la
franchise je peux vous dire et personne
ne vous tomber dessus bien rien il avait
dit la vérité vous l'avez vous avez raté
vous avez raté le train vous avez le
lança disons qu'on va jouer et je me
suis dit bon voilà il y avait beaucoup
de riz juridique j'étais j'ai fait les
12,7 possession oui les 12 semaines en
tant que femme ça m'embête de révéler
une grossesse avant douze semaines avec
tous les risques possibles et
inimaginables donc c'est pas le genre de
choses que moi je fais voilà
comment ça se passe
précisément c'est que l'avocat du
magazine il évalue le risque financier
mais à quelques milliers alors il n'a
pas la décision du smi c'est exactement
ça va coûter à mon avis plus que 30000
ça peut coûter aux 6000 euros il fait
rire et collation il fait une équation
et il voit combien de ventes
supplémentaires ça va faire et non mais
il a regardé les la balance est positive
qu'ils y vont c'est aussi simple que ça
n'enlèvera lui ils ont regardé le taux
diffusion du magazine que je vais pas
révéler à gueux là parce que quand même
c'est des secrets de deux shows voilà
mais il va regarder la diffusion du
magazine et en fonction de ça ça va être
évalué franchement pour moi autonome et
raccords à causeur avec françois
hollande
avec amène les croissants est-ce que ils
ont essayé de le faire de faire
interdire ou pas du tout non donc c'est
un ami n'était pas du tout au courant on
a l'impression que c'est moins grave que
ça
web après c'était y avait aussi la
question d'intérêt public dans la mesure
où ils ont quand même voilà et c'est le
président donc c'est le droit à la
formation le 3 l'information et ça veut
dire que cela n'arrivera que ça et
sortir et que lui et zemmour c'est que
ça va sortir
aujourd'hui ça s'est excusé moi mais
aujourd'hui avec l'internet est
aujourd'hui avec tout ce qui est en lien
à trois ans mais en digital là je parle
de ça demain ça perd de son intérêt
quand même
vendée non
qu'est la concurrence mais ils n'ont pas
été très malin ce qu'en général quand on
a ce genre de scoop on les met sous
embargo serre que même au niveau de
l'imprimerie c'est sous embargo pour pas
justement à voir mais ça me choque après
après moi je pense atteinte elle bosse
aussi myriam c'est un peu les deux ça
fait parler de demandes en vidéo d'aller
l'acheter ou sa part que les ventes vont
suivre ouais vous et vous oui ça va ils
vont certainement pas peut-être prendre
dix mille exemplaires mais sarah pas
forcément compenser le risque juridique